foreign
are you traveling with anyone
the reason for your troops all right
well congratulations
where are we going now we're gonna go
right over here
bring your bags up here
are you bringing any food no all right
no food no any alcohol alcohol clothes
and shoes
there's a lot of tonic lines
so maybe plans to open up a store or
something
oh
probably one number one
bottle broke in the whole box are you
mad the only one yeah
everything on board signals
so these are all for you only for
somebody else not for me and my friends
you know oh it's important
um
the subject had over 100 bottles of
tonic wine for us that's a red flag
because it's also a method of
concealment within those Hundred Bottles
maybe five or six could be loaded
one of them I have to crack over to make
sure it's tonic one
all right
[Music]
yeah it's just tonic wine there's
nothing there
you're going to keep this for yourself
to drink it whatever you want to do it's
not consuming right now yeah all right
now no no not now we had to open up a
few of them to make sure they were good
to go
but everything's checked out and we're
fine
information
he asked me if I can bring him back so
I'm bringing him back
what's his friend's name
yeah I don't know his legal name
short man yeah
for several years but you only know him
as short man he just asked me if I can
bring some shoes back for him his
personal shoes I I think so I don't I
don't know I didn't even ask him
so did he give you money
but you have to pay for an extra bag so
he's not giving you money for that oh
he's gonna have to yeah he's gonna have
to now
so we just got to make sure these
sneakers don't have anything inside
they're not supposed to have
especially when the sneakers that you
don't know anything about
it
just want to make sure everything checks
out
so we x-rayed the shoes and everything
appears to be all right
just look at this Louis Vuitton that's
not how that logo is
these are real
you don't know if they're real it's
copyright man Christian Louboutin
I don't think a friend asked him to
bring back the shoes I think he
purchased the shoes over there in
Jamaica knowing that they weren't real
with the intent to just use them over
here
listen the thing is is that you can't
bring knockoff stuff into the United
States that's the issue sorry are these
real you don't know no I'm like 99 sure
they're not real
but I don't want to bust your chops
because they look used right right and
it's not like you bringing it in for
commercial use to resell
even if they are counterfeit and he's
bringing in a pair that's his personal
use we can't do anything with that
because they already bought it they
bought it wherever they bought it and
they're using it you could tell they've
been used they've been worn off the fact
that the shoes look worn is what made us
uh Let It Go all right my friend you're
all set
thank you
all right man have a good day the exit
is right out there
[Music]
foreign
how long were you over there 10 days 10
days that's all you got in there ah I
have closed there
recently past year or two we've been
noticing a lot of young Travelers coming
from Colombia bringing a lot of party
drugs other than just the cocaine
now big drug that's becoming popular is
ketamine party drug they call it Special
K
usually found in toiletry bottles
[Music]
tell me this one
the Colombian flights there's no right
or wrong person to stop unfortunately
but I like to stick to the single
traveler with just a couple of bags make
sure we take out all the liquids any
other kind of products that we feel need
to be tested and make sure we don't miss
anything
okay
King Carlos
Carlos okay
[Music]
foreign
this is
liquid form in a lot of little perfume
bottles and shampoos so that's why we
were going through all those smaller
bottles a little small bottle like this
can be worth a lot of money
sonuel
just let it sit
good thing with this
I poured some out here on the table
looks like a old school trick of knowing
that something's not what it is
[Music]
drying off
a lot of times you'll see when we go to
grab something and it's loaded the
passenger will be all over it or
distance himself really far from it she
had no reaction at all so I was pretty
comfortable that there was nothing
hidden in there
okay
[Music]
adios
I understand may I see a password this
year the only one covet has been pretty
busy what do you know with this
here in Fargo we're looking for
Contraband or anything that can do any
harm to the General Public
we get a lot of bags shoes belts from
high quality merchants
how about these boxes over here
usually comes from South Asia can come
from any other part of the world it
looks like all these boxes belongs to
the same shipment yeah let's take one of
these down
whoa
n95 Mass
but we have a problem here because this
box is short kn95 but this one has n95
inside
mm-hmm
ka95 is produced in China and the n95 is
supposed to be produced here in the US
yep and the ship is imported from China
and the box is made in the USA
it was made in the USA it wouldn't be
coming from China they're not the real
deal
this is going to nursing homes different
healthcare providers
the general public I don't think they
know the difference between the original
and the counterfeit
and a lot of people can die because
they're not getting the right protection
are those the same day I know these are
actually 10.95 so these match the Box on
the outside they mixed in the good ones
with the bad ones so if you check this
one box it's covered yep deception
I have to open up every single box so we
could get an accurate count of how many
n95s we have and the KN 95s
many boxes do you think I'd say about
500. we got our work cut out for this
how much do you think they sell this in
the market five to ten bucks supplies
short they're desperate they will pay
top dollar
they're making tons of money on this
their profits and approaches all go to
different criminal organizations it's
terrible thinking that people will take
advantage and do this to us
cool great job guys
the shipment that we just finished
Counting
I had over 230 000 masks
next step we will call our HSI agents to
let them know about this counterfeit
shipment we'll hold it as evidence and
eventually it'll get destroyed
okay let's continue going to another
Warehouse
[Music]
all right what city are you going to
right now
[Music]
you guys on the vehicle
nope not yet
we are currently set up along the
highway
we got some information of a
semi-tractor trailer that is potentially
loaded with narcotics that's already in
the United States
if we can locate it uh based off the
information that we have we'll follow it
where it goes to find that Distribution
Hub because the people that are involved
with the next level of distribution are
a higher tier Target for us so deeper
into the organization
here we go
so one of these tractor trailers
this is it
it's got that red glow in the front of
the cab
and now we just gotta catch up
it's important to not lose this vehicle
we'll see where this goes
that's our goal
I have the ground eye
speed 75 miles an hour copy that we're
on one of the major highways running
North
unless it takes one of these next exits
it looks like we might be headed for Los
Angeles County
the Los Angeles area it's a massive
Distribution Hub and with the cargo
based smuggling the drug loads that can
come through and get anywhere from 500
kilos up to a thousand once they get to
the LA area they can be cut up and
broken down into smaller shipments and
ship anywhere
and we'll see where this goes
yep we're destined for Los Angeles
County
it's imperative that we take it down
before it gets cut up into those smaller
loads and goes deeper into the interior
of the United States
foreign
[Music]
yeah
today we have a flight that we're
interested in Bogota Colombia
all right how much money you traveling
in cash today
US Dollars yeah we got some passengers
we want to take a look at and ask some
questions what's the reasoning by going
on vacation to Bogota Colombia being
that it's a source country for narcotics
how long were you in Colombia for 17
days 17 days what are you bringing back
from Colombia yes float
we usually try to make as many stops as
we can while we're working the higher
risk flights to try and get as many
young Travelers coming from Colombia I'm
gonna go through all the bags make sure
we take out all the liquids any other
kind of products that we feel we need to
be tested bring an Alcohol Tobacco back
comes with 150 we're doing good if we
did 20 people
we're doing really good
where are you coming from man I flew
from from here to Bogota
um and then from Bogota to Cali Colombia
Cali Colombia
so we're just gonna do a bag he says now
let's go this way
okay
did you learn any Spanish while you were
down
you're almost a citizen
for all this
I think 1200 oh yeah I know that
you're creating too much and bringing
stuff back
that's why I like you already
so you say you own your own spot
so how long you been uh in business
I've been in business about five years
what are you doing today Wellness
those are like boards for your stomach
Force for the stomach after surgery
procedures and stuff
they went shopping down there I mean
they're cheaper there it's better to get
it while you're there yeah
over here you know they charge like a
hundred dollars for one of them it's how
much you are strong a hundred dollars no
I'm gonna beat everybody to cry
why don't you bring a camera I
had a whole bunch of groceries
the ginger ale you get Ginger out here
why would somebody buy Ginger Ale in
another country well it's not it's
that much sugar in it
we're just gonna just test it
way I ain't gotta take it you just want
to feel comfortable about
the Colombian Ginger
we got a little machine that tell us
everything
[Music]
sugar got water sugar yeah some
granulated sugar
okay we're good
all right
thank you man
thank you
oh wow what do you have
looks like it's in my pocket
white powder beautiful great job all
right how many uh boxes we have
17 total from Italy
those all jackets too
loaded
we have two bags
in each jacket
there's got to be a couple of dozen
jackets in each box
you first we want to know what the
substance is
reading through the plastic into the
substance it's gonna tell us what type
of narcotic if it's a narcotic at all
right
very good seasoning entire shipment
let's pack it up and we'll bring it back
we're going to be going back to a
building we're going to process
everything
see exactly how much we have
[Music]
two zipper Pockets per jacket both
Pockets have packages Academy
is a drug that's used for anesthesia
purposes and animals and in humans
but out on a street it's a party drug
used by a lot of younger people by
snorting shooting drinking and it causes
hallucinations out of body experiences
too much of it overdose causes death
64 grams in each bed it's gonna be a lot
so 128 per jacket three jackets is a
pound yeah it's gonna be one great
seizure
what's the uh total weight that we have
about 63 keys
that's approximately six million dollars
off the street
great job that's very good
this was a very gutsy move to bring in
60 kilos at one time we called our HSI
agents opening up an investigation we're
gonna see where it was going who it's
going to and I can foresee a lot of
people being arrested
[Music]
thank you
all right this is all your bags
everything yeah and you said you went
well all right you've been meeting
friends or family anything down there I
met a friend okay and did your friend
give you anything to bring back for them
nothing like that all right
foreign
[Music]
just last minute vacation okay yeah one
of my good friends lives there and
you need a break from I thought yoga was
very nice relaxing calming soothing
okay yeah
you read these
oh yeah
those are terrible tarot cards but many
talents
so how did you get to tarot reading I'm
not like interesting
well it's like the part of the day
okay
you know what I see
nothing
get you going
maybe she can read your Torah
give me give me a card give me a card
well he's scariest his curious no you
have to pick it all right Shuffle it
shuffle it all right
so what's in your mind the next seizure
yeah there you go so put it in your mind
and then just flip the part over however
you'd like
all right this says the universe
all right all right so let's see for the
reading
it civilizes the moment when the inner
and the outer worlds become a single
entity in some traditions the state is
described as Enlightenment and that we
will dance and sway along the flow of
life
so that means everything's flows exactly
I should co-mingle with the rhythms of
life and I have not seized any narcotics
today so I'm not actually complete and
I'm not actually fulfilled
Miss Caitlin you are a delightful person
to have to search thank you good luck
thank you for your time alrighty
get that seizure flowing I want a big
one today
we've landed just south of downtown LA
in the produce District immediate right
turn into the business
are going to take over
we've got our La team out here they are
now taking primary and we're just here
in support of them I've seen the
forklift come down the ramp uh over the
direction and stuff
our surveillance team is currently with
eyes on the vehicle that suspected to
have the narcotics and we're currently
just waiting
Forest Products are off the truck he has
those separated from the other one
it looks like there are workers on the
dock
[Music]
that are moving uh produce around on
pallets
well it looks like they're just keeping
three or four Brown pallets off to the
side you know these things can end a
million different ways so we just have
to kind of roll with the punches and and
make real-time decisions
it's dark traffic starts increasing
around here in the produce District once
it starts getting busy we're just gonna
lose track of those power
lock it down freeze the location copy
that we're going to make our approach
now
[Music]
canine's coming
the dog's hitting there you go
here we go
get the other one
[Music]
we're identifying this one okay
so these two are for sure that one is
for sure and that other one are the ones
that are confirmed
all that should be loaded yeah we're
gonna check them out
it's fresh garlic
what do you have yeah there's nothing
there
so right now they're uh they're emptying
the garlic
nothing
[Music]
it's up here
oh wow found it yeah it's right there
bingo
[Music]
so just place your bags on the counter
please
I'm currently assigned to passenger
processing at terminal four
but we do Immigration and Customs
we focus heavily on merchandise and just
making sure that you know everybody's
doing the right thing as far as
declaring goes
and your resident right make sure you
read this question carefully any
merchandise you purchased outside the US
that is coming back in today
or any gifts received that are coming
back in today this added purchase it is
something okay
so did you buy anything outside
and you have nothing to declare right
then you put a zero right there
all right you sign the bottom and that's
it so we're gonna have a quick back
check all right okay
put all your bags up here
so you're saying no food no alcohol no
tobacco what do you consider food
anything you put anywhere else to eat
like I got some like peanuts ah all
right
yeah
how long were you there Senegal
all right what were you doing there I'm
I'm my family so vacation
all right
what is that
that's a shampoo
[Music]
I found receipts
listen I thought you told me you didn't
buy anything
how much is this
is gold right
is this fake I don't know I don't know
but if this is real gold it's gonna have
a problem
how much is this how much is that in
dollars before I convert it myself
tell me man
this is like this is 61 dollars this for
my daughter they say it's not tall
18 carat
and this is
I think this is this right here that's
what yeah this is for that's worth more
than 60 bucks
I didn't buy this that's one of my
employees he asked to ask me to bring it
I think she got this for a long time
gave it to me
I think this has been with them for like
day is for yesterday
it's clear cut right in front of you I
know that's fine how come you didn't
declare it I'm gonna ask you okay I
didn't know see they gave it to me for
um
because if somebody's supposed to you're
bringing somebody else's stuff but I
know how so she's just like a sister my
husband gave it to me that's all fine
but you have to declare okay I
understand remember when I asked you
that like three times so I understand
you get it if you were to declare it it
would have been much easier
people need to declare everything they
purchase sometimes they don't declare
like this gentleman didn't declare
anything today but we found some gold
Juliano you know you have to pay Duty on
this right
you got to pay the government their
taxes
all right let's convert this see what we
got here
gold Duty rate is five and a half
percent so we multiply that and we're
left with only 95 bucks you gotta pay
today that's it
you're not even bringing nothing to
nobody
I just need a receipt you pay right
there they give you a receipt and you're
good to go all right okay
I found receipts we gave him his
exemptions and at the end of the day he
paid the duty and walked out of here so
let that be a lesson
thank you
for all this is outbound what we're
looking for is the inbound store okay
today we picked this Warehouse we look
for where the shipment is coming from
the shipper uh what is going to
destination whether the shipment is
being packed the packaging told us a lot
okay
what's the best one here
so what is funny one but is bigger than
the other yeah
coming from overseas
yeah
let's open it
oh
[Music]
Louis Vuitton wow we gotta check this
it's heavy
oh
we have bags inside our bag
YSL same Laurent
this is not white so
they don't package like this
[Music]
see how hard it is
very bumpy the stitching is horrible
this is bad quality stuff we have a lot
of branded items but I can fill the
material it was like thin smelled like
plastic
it's definitely counterfeit these
criminals use the internet to sell the
products they make a lot of money like
one of these bags like three thousand
dollars plus when people go and search
for a product that they like they see
the product and it looks original and
people buy it
let's see the brand they say oh wow but
they don't know exactly what they're
paying for this entity they take
advantage of that and they imitate the
product and they make a good money on
those
so I'm gonna detain this do an inventory
of every single box and send it to the
import specialist absolutely
because he looks like it's the same
thing the same
even Footwear
Jordan
let's see
oh Balenciaga Balenciaga
the shoes goes for about 900 retail
it's crazy
this imitation is almost exact why are
they real when you wear something like
that
so how many we have here 10 boxes on one
skid
sending kind of fit product it's a
federal fence
what we're gonna do we're gonna put
everything together and uh we just send
it to the import specialist
and the product gets destroyed
this is what we're here for and whenever
I find something it's a good day for me
all right good work guys
another day in the life of customs
[Music]
let's put it back up there sir
both of these bags of yours yes anybody
give you anything to bring here nothing
okay
this guy's by himself younger male
coming from Colombia with just a couple
of bags when I stopped and start looking
through his passport he had a lot of
trips so it became more interesting to
me
how long were you in Colombia uh four
days five days
what's this for it's for my face
what's the straw
spinner
I pulled out face wash and there was no
straw in the pump
which raised suspicion as to we need to
test some of those liquids out
everything in here is yours right what's
in here
that's getting gritty it's starting to
crystallize
isn't this one right here
[Music]
we're gonna get all liquids out take
them in the back start testing on the
liquids
you see
two little granulars on there all these
little specks yeah that's probably
crystallizer
Colombians Master disguise when it comes
to concealments
[Music]
that went through fast
there you go
ketamine
Special K
Academy the Palm what is it's a
tranquilizer you don't know what the
concentration of this ketamine is people
are taking it they might take too much
go down and never come back
that one tested positive Academy too
let's go to the next one
yeah that's because it has to be
airtight otherwise right otherwise it'll
crystallized yep
[Music]
yeah another one
more ketamine so it looks like we have
four bottles
[Music]
1.68
we're gonna detain them right now la
manotra
the academy and the amount that we have
here didn't meet the threshold for
federal prosecution
so we contacted our state and locals
here in Georgia they're going to come
down and they'll hopefully try and get
more information from him
I need you to level four fingers flat on
that pad
some people smuggle because they're in a
bad situation some people get coerced
into doing something they don't want to
do and some people do it because they're
entrepreneurs and they'll think it's
easy to go there and get something to
eat bring it over here flip it make a
lot of money
I don't know the full details of that
but according to his password he has a
few trips I can almost be certain that
he's probably done this a few more times
[Music]
thank you
three four five six we got one more
right here
take it out keep going
oh yes
boom
it's a pretty big load
what's good the pallets were loaded just
took us a while to kind of get to this
point
we still have two more pallets to go but
it looks like pretty much every box has
Contraband in it so this pile is going
to get a little bit bigger
produce loads are unfortunately used as
cover loads for Narcotics Contraband
loads like this are coming through the
border every day this is a bad time to
tell you guys I'm allergic to garlic
these packages here from what they feel
feels like crystals so it's probably
crystal meth
see how this is shape difference yeah
this may be Coke this may be fentanyl I
don't know if you ever saw me do this
before if you thought
Yeah the more that sounds like a wood
block the higher pitch in my experience
has been Fentanyl and then the thought
is more
it's a mixed load but the predominance
of this uh cargo is going to be meth
the meth production in Mexico has
increased exponentially especially this
year
we're gonna run out of room
they're using large loads and large
storage areas like this tractor trailer
here in large quantities
I think that's it it's a lot these are
quite large for meth packages a lot of
times we get them in about the one pound
these feel like they're about one kilo
each
it's just over 500 kilograms of just
meth
13 packages
of cocaine and Fentanyl
today is a success we took over 1200
pounds of poison off the streets of LA
here and we are going to continue the
investigation and pursue the subjects
that we're supposed to pick it up and
work the criminal Network that brought
this all the way from Mexico to L.A
these semi trucks are crossing from
Mexico into the United States every day
just one of these getting through can
have a significant impact on the drug
trade
so every seizure is a significant
seizure
[Music]